well hey there thank you for being here
especially if this is your first time
with us Adventist or otherwise so I've
got a question for
y'all was Ellen White who she claimed to
be was Ellen White who she claimed to
be why or why
not let us know in the comment section
down
below is she a reliable messenger from
God or a
deceiver did God show her copious
amounts of Visions to confirm the SDA
Church as God's last day Remnant people
Etc like I said comment your answer down
below let us hear what you think tonight
we're going to be examining this
question and I've got two guests that
were so gracious to share some of their
time with us and interact with it some
months ago I came across a couple of
videos from Adventist pastor Kevin
Morgan where he was interacting with
some of Dr Steve dy's
book LG white a psychobiography so I
reached out to both of the individuals
to set up a cordial back and forth and
see where the evidence leads which is
what we are going to be witnessing this
evening I will simply be facilitating
and moderating if need be but I'm
looking forward to the
engagement Kevin Morgan is the author of
Sabbath rest is the there's something
missing in your busy life and he is also
the co-author with Marcela Anderson king
of More Than Words a study of
inspiration and Alan White's use of
sources in the Desire of Ages he has
published articles in Ministry on New
Testament studies authentic worship and
literacy dependency and has edited
several books on church history and
Biblical teaching he holds a ba in
theology with minors and applied
theology in biblical languages as well
as a master's degree in homiletics from
from my alma mater Southern Adventist
University he has served as a pastor
since 1985 and he lives with his family
in North
Carolina and Dr Daly a returning guest
he is the author of 28 books 10 directly
related to l&g White and adventism he
taught religion history and psychology
at the University level with a 24-year
tenure in 7th Adventist institutions
including Lolinda University and La
Sierra University during those years he
was also a campus chaplain and a pastor
he has been licensed as a psychologist
since 1992 and his PhD in Psychology he
also holds an MA in history and a
doctorate in religion from Claremont
School of Theology where his
dissertation in history and religion
related to Ellen White and
adventism one final housekeeping item if
you like what we are doing here and you
want to see more of it you want to see a
wider variety of content you can partner
with us at answering adventism tocom and
visit the donate page viewer support
helps us not only reach Adventists with
the truth but also with tangible needs
that many leaving the movement have uh
things like resources books Etc and we
are happy to be able to do that so
please consider supporting us if you
feel led to do so and only then I want
to emphasize that if you are not giving
to your local church do not give to us
he's like I appreciate the the desire to
support but some of you that reach out
if you are not giving to your church do
not be giving to us please
support your local assembly before us
please please please hear me on that
that's just a personal and I believe
biblical conviction but with that
said gentlemen thank you so much for
being here and
welcome hey good evening both of you to
both of you Steve good to meet you
finally take before we formally get into
things I want to give each of you five
minutes uninterrupted to put forth your
case Kevin we will start with you let
the audience know some of the general
reasons for why you think Ellen White is
who she claimed to be and should be
believed as a true Messenger of God then
we will let Steve do the same before you
two interact on some of the specifics
when you hear
this that means you have one minute left
when you hear it a second time that
means your time is up so just wrap up
your thought um if you're in the middle
of a thought when that happens feel free
to finish that thought but that will
indicate that your time is up I will
start your time when you begin speaking
right after I get the timer set up
here all right I will begin the time
when you begin speaking and the floor is
yours okay feels like I'm uh taking a
final exam or something here uh let me
let me just start by by saying that I
have this notion that for different
people to come away with different
Notions about illen white it depends
upon your beginning with her and whether
it was a positive experience or not and
what I'm going to present is the fact
that for me it was very positive among a
number of factors so I'm going to go to
my screen here and talk about some of
the books that were impactful for me
that's where I I began to
conceptualize um
for for her actually need to go to my
object lesson right here if you want to
go full string this was the book that my
mom got when I was a
baby that made an impact on her life and
I heard about it you know from then on
out my mom would read it while she was
nursing me and then she would take me
with her to the library to see if it was
lining up with history and it and it was
so back in 1958
she became a sth day Adventist and um I
grew up with this notion that Ellen
White was a nice person a good person
and a helpful person because my mom had
studied history in
college and it just did not seem
like things fit together very well I
mean it was it was mostly conflicts
between nations and it didn't seem to
have a Rhyme or Reason but the great
controversy gave her a sense of
continuity of God's guidance in the
church and leading people to understand
the Bible so that was the first thing um
then the first book that I ever just
picked up all right we can go to full
screen on to the my screen on this one
was early
writings
and to be quite honest with you I wasn't
much of a reader I had to kind of force
myself to read stuff when I was a kid
but I started reading early writings and
I was uh Amazed by it it as much as when
I would read 1 Corinthians 13 and think
How could somebody know to be able to
express these kinds of ideas um their
way beyond my experience 1 Corinthians
13 talked about God's love in a way that
nobody else ever had and I said you know
Paul must be inspired and in a similar
way when I was reading early writings
I I read these these descriptions of the
the conflict behind the scenes and I I
knew there were some Bible verses that
kind of gave sketchy details about her
but um this was this was different and
and so when I read it I just I just
loved it and I also read some of her own
early experience and I'm thinking that
must not have been an early writings
because it doesn't talk too much about
her early experience there but I began I
I I related to her experience as a
conscientious follower of God and her
conversion um when she was she came back
from the the camp meeting and just saw
things in a different light I had a
similar experience when I was baptized I
was a young child I was not quite even
nine years old when I was baptized but
when I was baptized I just walked
outside and I just I just felt
that this was something very special
that I had shared with with Jesus that I
knew he had been baptized and now I was
baptized with him and I have to say I
didn't understand a lot of things about
what it meant to be a Christian at the
time but it was it was just a a very
special thing so I related to her okay
well found out about um that there were
issues against her my mom had this book
in her Library LG White and the critics
and then I read Desire of Ages and I
spent so much time reading it it was
just so such a blessing to me and along
with that I was reading other books this
was the the story of Jesus from the
living New Testament and all of these
things just fit fit together well for me
and finally I said I need to read the
same book my mom did and when I read
great
controversy what impressed me most I
knew it was a lot of history and there
are a lot of footnotes and stuff but
what impressed me most about it was that
it was Bible Bible Bible Bible I didn't
expect that I really didn't expect that
and I expected it to be written more
like the early stuff so it was it was a
very different thing and so it was this
this experience and then being
confronted with well I guess that's it
huh I ended up this this book on white
life soap after many years after the
issues that came up in 1980s anyway
there we go
thank you for that Kevin all right Steve
we will now hear from you let people
know who you are uh and some of the
general reasons why you think Ellen
White was not who she claimed to be and
should not be trusted you have five
minutes and the same rules will apply
the floor will be yours and the time
will begin once you begin
talking well thank you miles for the
invitation thank all of you who are
listening tonight uh for joining us it's
a privilege to be here my experience for
the last several years has been that um
Adventist
apologists either are terribly ignorant
about their own history or they are
deliberately dishonest and obviously the
last one is more troubling than the
first one but the king of all Adventist
apologists that Kevin alluded to was FD
nickel uh wrote he wrote Ellen Whit and
her critics uh in 1950 just shortly
before I was born
and um when I was a kid you know any
criticism of Ellen White or anyone who
questioned her oh FD nickel has already
handled that he's already addressed that
he's got all the answers and uh so I
grew up being told that you know by
Adventist and in Adventist schools and
even when I went to pu to start out that
that was the party line that FD nickel
had it all together he was the ultimate
apologist and no critic could stand up
against him and over the years as I got
my masters in history as I did two
doctoral dissertations all relating to
Ellen White and adventism as I taught
uh adventism Adventist history at the uh
graduate level uh for more than two
decades or I should say for most of two
decades
um it became obvious to me that niichel
was not an honest person and that
troubled me a lot uh there are all kinds
of where he was not honest um but the
two that I'll just mention briefly the
one will be talking about a bit which is
the shut door U nickel wrote a ton on
that and he claimed that he used all the
original sources and Source
documentation which is absolutely not
true he he deliberately deceived his
audience and that troubled me a great
deal as I found how true that was and
the other was that I'll mention uh the
amalgamation of man and Beast and Ellen
White's racist statements there and
nickel went out of his way to cover that
up to try to make it sound like she
wasn't racist when she clearly was
racist uh everyone knew she was racist
it was right at the time of the Civil
War she was about ready to get thrown
out of the church from what she had said
um so Uriah Smith desperately wrote a
saving pamphlet explaining what she
supposedly meant and uh he explained
this in great detail and it took the
heat off her as far as the blacks in the
Civil War were concerned but it was
still a very racist pamphlet and uh both
Ellen and James endorsed what uh Smith
said they sold his books and and this
got Ellen off the hook but it was still
very much a racist explanation FD nickel
knew that good and well and he
deliberately covered it up and came up
with a completely different theory that
was nothing to do with what Ellen
believed or thought or wrote so that
troubled me a lot and obviously most aan
apologists aren't anywhere near in FD
Nichols class as far as intelligence
study the man wrote thousands and
thousands of pages as an
apologist and um so he's the hero that
most of the evanst apologists go to and
feed from his trough but um what I find
with most apologists I run into is that
they strain it an n and swallow a camel
they use ad ad hominum arguments against
you or they don't address the big
picture they try to pick out some little
thing and make a big deal of it uh as I
looked over
Kevin's looked at Kevin's webcast on my
book um the struct me you know that he
was straining at a net and swallowing a
camel he he made a big deal over me
referring to
uh you know small things in the book
that were really um ridiculous you know
I I as I look back at it um I can't help
but say Ron grael is someone I know
personally and he was listed in the book
as assistant director of the white
estate well that's exactly what he was
was he he's called assistant secretary
or assistant director Arthur white was
the secretary or the director um but
Kevin made a big deal as if I didn't
know what I was talking about and Ron uh
agreed to that description of him in the
book he was on my reading committee so
to try to say I didn't know who Ron was
or I didn't know what his title was I
just found that very disingenuous and uh
there were several other examples I can
use but we can talk about him as we
go can't hear
you thank you for that Steve with that
said let's now interact with some of
this and break the
ice first things first Kevin you took a
objection to a claim that Steve made
regarding Joseph Bates seven-year Theory
I want to play a clip of that and then
look at the quote you referenced in
Steve's book then the floor will be open
for both of you to interact on it so
let's listen
in she descri describes here or he
describes here
about um at this time Joseph Bates had
not formulated his seven-year Theory
which would predict that the second
coming would occur on October 22 1851 a
theory which whites would accept as we
have shown well he didn't show it and
that's one of my big concerns is that he
showed that she believed that Jesus was
coming soon but never anything specific
about a seven-year Theory and in fact
she had a vision before the Fulfillment
of the 1851 time period in which she was
shown that they would be disappointed
and that got James back on track before
the event actually took place we do have
documentary evidence on that
all right so I'm
100 go ahead okay the quote you
referenced Kevin is from page 119 which
reads as
follows quote at this time Joseph Bates
had not formulated his 7-year Theory
which would predict that the second
coming would occur on October 22nd 1851
a theory which the whites would accept
as we have shown as Ellen White would
confirm through vision
M close quote so I'm not saying it was
nefarious but I'm not sure why you left
off the last part of the sentence uh in
your video clip Kevin either way I just
wanted to make sure the entirety of the
claim was shown so Steve you were
referring back to chapter four and five
in your book when you say you proved
this claim Kevin disagrees and says you
only showed where she said Jesus is
coming soon never anything specific
about endorsing the seven-year Theory
and the Camden New York vision of 1851
was uh referred to to help support this
let's hear your response to this and
then the floor will be open for both of
you to go back and
forth sure I'm 100% familiar with the
quotes on both sides um I find that the
apologists are typically not familiar
with the quotes that
uh demonstrate that Ellen was
indeed um buying into to baates Theory
and uh we know for a fact James
initially was pretty sympathetic to it
but by 1849 he was starting to distance
himself from it and him and Ellen were
actually seeing it from a different
perspective and uh James wanted to move
in a mission oriented Direction even in
as early as
1849 but Ellen was still strongly
believing that
um you know this uh seven-year theory
was going to materialize let me just
share some of the quotes as to why I say
I believe that this is demonstrated in
the source documentation first in
January 31
1849 to those who are receiving the Seal
of the Living God I saw it was the will
of God that the Saints should cut loose
of every encumbrance dispose of their
houses lands before the time of Trouble
Comes um very shortly after this she
says it's only three months before the
time of trouble is going to begin
and I'll read that quote she prophesied
that the time of trouble was only three
months away and and they are to make a
covenant with God by sacrifice I saw
they should sell if they laid their
property on the Altar and earnestly
inquired for Duty so she's tell people
telling people to sell their hom sell
their property sell their possessions
that the time is that close let me read
three more statements here right from
the same time period early writing 64 in
have you given me June 27 1850 my
accompanying angel said time is almost
finished do you reflect the lovely image
of Jesus as you should then I pointed to
Earth and saw there would have to be a
getting ready among those who have a vo
embrace the third Angel's message she
said Get Ready Get Ready Get Ready you
have to die a greater death to the world
than you have died I saw that there was
a great work to do for them and but
little time in which to do it she
continues some of us have had time to
get the truth and to advance step by
step and every step that we have taken
has given us strength to take the next
but time is almost finished and what we
have had years to learn they will have
to learn in a few months they will also
have much to unlearn and much to learn
again so why in the world is she's
saying they have three months here um
which fits perfectly with the seven-year
Theory because she's saying the time of
trouble is going to begin in three
months and that was to
last less than a year which would fit
perfectly with the October 22 1851 date
are you are you familiar with uh with
when that was actually written yes I was
it was
62750 no it was it was written in
49 no the the June 2750 is the date of
the three-month one uh the other one the
first one I read was in
1849 yes okay the last two I read were
June 27 1850 the third one this is the
last time Ellen makes a shutd door
statement and I'll tell you why this is
the last time and this is 18 June 21
1851 she said I saw that Jesus prayed
for his enemies but that should not
cause to pray for the Wicked World whom
God has rejected when he prayed for his
enemies there was hope for them and they
could be benefited and saved by his
prayers and also after he was a mediator
in the outer apartment of the whole
world but now his spirit and sympathy
were withdrawn from the world and our
sympathy must be with Jesus and must be
withdrawn from the ungodly present tense
now this is the last shutd door
statement she makes and the reason that
she shuts off early before the October
22 1851 date is because she was
expecting the time of trouble to come
and by the summer of
1851 she could see the time of trouble
had not come everything was just the way
it had been her predictions had fallen
flat uh she was a false prophet and now
she had to do reparations she had to try
to figure out how in the heck am I going
to deal with this so this is when she
starts making these other
statements um august 19 1851 I have
never stated or written that the world
will be doomed or damned I never have
under any circumstance used this
language to anyone however sinful I have
ever had messages of reproof for those
who use such harsh Expressions well
that's just a direct lie for seven years
she had been saying that uh probation
had closed that the wicked were lost
that God had judged the world um and now
she's trying to say she never made any
statements like this at all which is
just completely untrue and um you know
Steve let's let's there there's a lot of
good stuff there I want to make sure
Kevin has a good amount of time to
respond to that um so let's let's halt
there and then we can pick the the back
and forth back up but Kevin I want to
hear your or let you have the floor to
to respond to some of
that yeah everything that you've given
you you have been able to kind of put it
together in your mind and it makes good
sense for what you're saying and in your
book you said it was consistent with and
I would say I can understand why you
would say it's consistent with but the
burden of proof is to to show in any way
that she she has written or that James
has written that they identified with
the
7year theory because that that is the
contention you can you can prove that
she believed it was the time was short
and I will agree with you within the
first year
1845 they did believe that he would come
within the the that that period and that
was that was the concurred and agreed
upon uh view of those who accepted the
bridegroom uh Theory to explain why
Christ did not come recently I took U
all of the issues of the Jubilee
standard and I wanted to say this to you
by the way your book has stimulated me
to do deeper a deeper dive on this
subject because I never thought that I
would even need to I didn't I didn't see
the need to but but because you have
brought these things out and because you
are very efficient I I do like the way
that you you footnote it's a lot easier
than a lot of formulations of of
footnotes it was easier for me to look
things up but when I when I started
reading there are the reason why you may
think of it as
nitpicking I'm what I'm pointing out is
that if you have carefully placed points
of Truth and all of those truth all of
those points are accurate then you come
together and you can formulate a a
proper conclusion but if you generalize
too quickly without being very clear
about those different points then you
may actually skew it slightly it's like
putting a puzzle together you have to
have all of the pieces so I went back
and I transcribed and edited all of the
Jubilee standards that's available and I
looked at it and I realized that there
was a tendency of people in that first
year
including um Israel Damon you're
probably familiar with that name um Hira
medson that he he wrote for the Jubilee
standard but Ellen White did not she was
Ellen Harmon obviously and James White
did not but there is a there's a a finer
point on the distinction between them
and that's what I want to show here so
if we can go to the full screen uh miles
and I'm you have to you'll have to share
your screen again since your internet
dropped if you were wondering earlier
folks while he gets that set up if you
were wondering earlier why there was
some uh screen malfunction it was just
due to a little bit of a tech issue um
but no worries he is back so you will
just need to share your screen again
Kevin okay cool all right here we go
this is the earlier earlier statement
where where Steve points out about the
seven-year Theory the second one was
like like it said a reference back to
the the proofs and I was just going
through a number of of things that did
not seem accurate to me based on what I
had studied so uh it was not that that
presentation I was not a point BYO
reputation of what was in it it was just
a couple of points that came that popped
out when I was reading that particular
chapter
but so I've gone back to document this
and and so that it's in his words but
for our purposes in this chapter Bates
was also responsible for convincing
James and Ellen White to embrace the
seven-year Theory which would once again
set a date for the end of the world this
time on October 22
1851 so then we have the the question is
is there sufficient evidence to say that
they entirely bought in on the seven
years Theory that's the point that has
to be proved so from there I'm going to
uh go to the next statement and this is
this is a
running uh commentary by Douglas Morgan
on his article uh we'll get the
reference at the end but he says bat's
contemplation of the details of the
sanctuary service in the day of
atonement led him to a momentous
conclusion the pre-advent Judgment that
began in October o uh October 1844 would
last seven years and thus in October
1851 Jesus will be gathering in the
Harvest with his sickle on the White
Cloud now here's where I agree with you
Steve on this um you said he had you
know at a certain point Bates didn't
have this Theory you know Bates theory
he didn't come out with it in in 45 he
didn't come out with in 46 it wasn't
until 1850 that he came up with this
idea of seven years so we're in
agreement we're in agreement that Bates
is the source of the seven-year Theory
you and I agree on that and um as far as
I could tell from dou Douglas he uh he
goes on to say when it was published he
made his case in an explanation of the
typical and antitypical Sanctuary a
16-page pamphlet published in March
1850 the last of the seven Works he
issued from New Bedford starting in 1846
but then he this is his conclusion from
it
both Ellen and James White sharply
opposed this claim now we're going to go
to the evidence for that Doug came to
the conclusion that that was the case we
he and I got uh talked about this
recently and the basis for saying that
the uh pamphlet was published in March
is the fact that he left where it was
published and he was traveling up in
Canada east and I had seen those
articles when I was looking through some
of the early Publications so it had to
be published where he was until uh
before he went up there so March is
probably right um based on
that but he his conclusion is that they
were sharply opposed to the claim um and
in the review and Herald xtrap published
uh July 21st 1851 that the third Angels
message should not be hung on time for
time will never be a test again that's
what I had at the bottom of my screen
she had this particular particular
message in July but that's not the only
one the passage of time itself would
have overthrown bat's position but he
apparently ceased promoting his theory
before that
happened okay all right Kevin let's
let's give oh go ahead just let me
finish the quote and then then we can go
back after Ellen's article in July and
another repudiation from James in August
interest died down with no buildup of
anticipation heading into October over
now I don't know if you've studied this
part and would agree with that part um
but the part where we disagree is
whether Ellen and James did buy into
that theory that's where you and I
disagree disagree here here's the
difference I the quotes you've given fit
perfectly with my understanding and
Theory the quotes I'm giving do not fit
with yours you explain to me and I'll
I'll let you know that wrong Gra
supported what I'm saying here he was
questioning Ellen's buying end of the
seven-year Theory and I showed him hey
why in the world is she saying three
months here why is she saying the time
of trouble's going to specifically start
in three months which fits perfectly
within the time of trouble ending in uh
October 22 1851 based on the things she
said about the time of trouble uh and
and grael admitted yes
uh fair enough you're right um she does
say she does say few months but then
then you know in this vaunted book of uh
nicholl's he he points out that she
repeats that same
statement in
54 yeah and that's another problem is
that um so if it if it was specific to
the seven-year Theory how would it have
any validity after that because she
still makes all kinds of stupid date
setting statements after 1851 which is
really quite interesting you'd think she
would have learned her lesson after how
many times she screwed up um okay it was
let's go let's go to her the evidence of
of some other statements if you don't
mind I I want to hear your explanation
for that a few month three month
statement what what is your explanation
of it why did she said she did believe
it was soon
but she did not set but she did not buy
into a specific
Theory and that was what I said in my
video gonna start in three months which
she did not say three months well a few
months almost everyone would say a few
months and three months are synonymous
so let's go to let's go to the quotes
and I will answer your question how
about that okay can we go go to the
quotes let's go to the quotes yeah all
right okay she says different times were
set for the Lord to come and were urged
upon the Brethren but the Lord showed me
that they would pass by for the time of
trouble must come before the coming of
Christ and that every time that was set
and passed would only weaken the faith
of God's people now this is in Spring of
1845 so this is the first statement
where she makes the claim that we
shouldn't be setting times so this is
this is a pattern when you see a pattern
it should help you to make a better uh
evaluation okay that's the first one
that's in 45 because as I read through
the Jubilee standard they they in the
Jubilee standard they predicted that he
would come in Passover time and there
there are numerous authors that pointed
to that and then when he didn't come at
Passover then they would set another one
they said well he should come by October
of 45 and she's saying all of this time
uh setting of times is only going to
bring uh uh discouragement on the people
and weaken the faith of God's people so
that's in 45 now we're going to move on
okay may we should just stop we should
stop right there because she said a time
that Christ would return by the end of
June
1845 that shows you what a mixed up
young lady she was she's saying no time
here but then uh she sets a time that
the Lord will return by the end of June
1845 when she I I've never seen such a
statement Steve I'm going to show it to
you okay and now and you're and you're
going to verify that she says by the end
of June the Lord will come or is it is
it a more
generalized and also when she's
confronted about that oh I misunderstood
it was in the language of
Canaan you're not going to quote her
you're going to quote somebody else I
know the statement you're talking about
bck who was her closest friend she was
not her together they were close they
were extremely close friends until they
were not left that relationship because
Ellen was repeatedly proven wrong yeah
okay well hold on just a second on that
on that on that point okay I I'll let
you bring the the quotation out but they
there is no evidence they were close
friends statement traveled together
constantly both before and after and got
married they did not they did not they
did no there's no evidence for it yes
there is the statement the statement
that you use to to back that is somebody
else's evaluation of Burdick's own
statement berdick does not say she was
close friends quing it it's berdick
quoting it to Miles Grant who put it in
his book but she did not say they were
close friends it's an
i i i it's in one of my videos she said
put it in one of my videos and I didn't
know that we were gonna have to deal
with this tonight said that she Trav
with Ellen both before and after she did
not she did not I'll read
it you know she did not she what verdict
said was I became
acquainted with Ellen White in
1845 maybe to help just facilitate a
little bit here to make sure both sides
are being heard Kevin I think his claim
is not that lucenda either verbatim said
I was a friend of alen white but he is
saying it can be deduced based on the
fact that clearly if you're traveling
around with somebody you're more than
just an
acquaintance exactly but but okay the
the idea that she's a friend comes from
the word acquaint that she became
acquainted and the fact the the
description of her traveling around with
her is not backed up by any other
statement and in fact her own statement
she does not say that she traveled
around with her she's not from the same
town in Maine who Ellen White did know
and who is related to her is her first
husband John Howell and I have tracked
his life I I even got uh Lucinda bick's
um uh madeen name found out the town
that she she grew up in um where they
got married all of that I put into in a
video so there it's it's a it's
a a supposition that they were well
known and that they traveled the ones
that I can that I can document who
traveled with her were the
files James White Sarah uh ell Ellen
White's sister and then one other
brother that she mentioned and those are
ones that traveled uh Israel Damon
traveled now she may have gone to one of
the places where she was but she was not
a traveling companion with Ellen White
there is no evidence that that backs
that point up now she may have she may
have crossed paths with her so what I'm
what I'm trying to just trying to say
she she may have been at one of the
places where she was but she did not
travel with her that is not her claim
she heard Ste Steve let's hear your
response to that she heard the statement
she heard Ellen White's response to them
are you just saying that she made all
this stuff up that Ellen White never
said this stuff is that your position
it's it is hearsay based on a later
statement not on an early statement it
is her in the description and I and I
point this out the language indicates
that she is she is acquainted with Ellen
White and she knows of these things but
is not it is not her talking with Ellen
White that's not the statement that that
she makes it's here her directly hearing
Ellen White respond to these questions
why did the Lord first of all I mean
look at the context here Ellen's First
Vision in December of
1844 how does it start out the Lord
showed me the day and hour of his coming
but she never announced it well and when
she was
either and when she was no man knows
himself so how's God gonna show Ellen
the day and the
hour I mean that she said when she came
out of vision somebody asked her if she
if she knew she said I don't remember
what he said so it was with it was if
you if you will follow the vision she's
describing a chronology of what takes
place before Christ comes and she says
as we get close to the end he announces
the day and the hour she's not saying
that she got some message that she
forgot she is describing the chronology
of what took place all right could we go
to the next slide we heard the voice of
God like many Waters which gave us the
day and hour of Jesus coming that's
that's the narrative yeah that's the
narrative people asking her so people
are asking her hey
when's he gon to come you got the day or
the hour going here and so she said I
don't know he gets this other Vision
claiming he's GNA come by June of
1845 and then when that fails she gets
confronted again and and she says no I
misunderstood it was in the language of
Canan uh it was actually the second
planning so it will be in September of
this year and that passes again and
she's wrong again I mean when you go
back
I mean let's go back to Donald cas's new
book where he shows was involved with
dat setting all through the millerite
time as well I mean she was involved in
all kinds of date
setting I I I understand that you accept
that that's good evidence I do not you
don't think and and I have Jan
Andrews who was a close
associate well
Miss berdick was not she didn't come
from the same town she didn't live in
the in the towns she didn't travel we
have Jay and Andrews in a statement that
he makes and he said there was never an
announcement of any kind of a day or an
hour that he knew of we also have Maran
Stow who was a lifelong friend of Ellen
White she was also in Paris she knew her
we have the dates when they met we have
conversations that she has described she
was a close associate of Ellen White and
she was with her on a number of
different occasions on different Visions
she's one of multiple Witnesses for
those Visions so the quality of the
testimony is much stronger for the one
who was there on numerous occasions with
her who was a close confident with her
and who wrote about it later so I I can
present I I didn't know that I was going
to need to present these these articles
but they are in my new book I have
amassed these testimonies that respond
to these issues and I thank you for
bringing them up so that I can respond
to them but here we have only a
secondary source Miss berdick who is
giving this in at earliest
1874 it's republished
by Miles Grant later okay but it's the
earliest is
1874 and she is recollecting something
her
husband John Howell was such a
notorious uh competitor with Ellen White
that he traveled where she was and Miles
Grant also traveled where she was to
speak against her so they
they they do have a clear bias we know
they have a bias and when you do history
you have to take into account the bias
of the of the witness all right so
in hold hold on hold on hold on yeah
let's let's let Steve respond to some of
that because I just don't want it to get
too buried and too lost hold that
thought and then actually after this
we're going to come back up on this I
want to play another clip from your
broadcast Kevin but it's on the same
same topic and so save that for that
period Steve um Say What You Need to to
that and then like I said I want to play
that next clip yeah miles Grant
obviously wasn't a pro Ellen white
person no one's trying to claim he was
but but berdick was she was a friend she
did travel with Ellen she was in the
churches she talks about how this June
Vision that Ellen had was accepted and
received in all the churches that they
went to um you know you're you're you're
acting like she didn't even hardly know
Ellen White when she she did here's
firsthand what Ellen said it was it was
spoken in the churches all over and and
you're acting like oh she came up with
this in 1874 no she remembered this
clearly from the 1840s when she was with
Ellen and Miles knew her then too he
happens to write his book several years
later but he knew her this was
documented in the 40s this is not like
some ancient memory the way Ellen White
comes up with you know and when she
denies all her shut door statements in
1874 and
1883 yet when you take the source
document statements themselves between
1844 and 1851 she's saying the most
ridiculous shut door stuff you can
imagine and then she completely denies
it in 1874 and 1883 and nickel takes
makes those later statements as if
they're the source documentation this is
the kind of stuff I have to put up with
with Adventist
apologist well you you are you're I
think that that bias makes a difference
for both of us because you're willing to
take her um a statement from
1874 and I am going back to
1845 and I am going to 1850
for these specific statements and that's
what I would like to bring up because
you have brought it up I I'm going to
look up Andrew's statement so that um
while while you're doing that Kevin not
you don't rely on me but
on what he actually declares so I'm
going to while while you're looking that
up I'm gonna I'm going to play the next
clip here because I want to keep things
we got some some more stuff obviously
tonight to look at I love the the back
and forth I love the dialogue here um I
want to play another clip though from
your video Kevin um that is still in the
same vein and then uh I will see you
guys on the other
side another matter is the issue of the
shut door which he fails to understand
he says that in her first Vision she
says that probation had closed that's a
misunderstanding of what the shut door
is about what they came to understand
the shut door to being was that there
are two apartments in the Heavenly
sanctuary as Hebrews says it's in the
Greek that it's multi compartmental it's
holy
places anyway in the first
Vision she refers to the
144,000 that sets the bar pretty high
for how many people should be ready for
Jesus when he
comes at its maximum the Advent movement
has about 50,000 and certainly far fewer
after the
disappointment so the first Vision
actually points forward to a greater
work probation hadn't
closed but people had made up their mind
and those who fell off the
pathway none of them got back up on the
pathway for the Midnight
Cry she was right
so I feel badly
for the
author writing a book that's based on so
many assumptions he should have
consulted some more people before he
published he has a a group of people and
he refers to them in the front of the
book and ostensibly they looked at this
but they didn't catch these major
glaring errors that I have just
mentioned and so many
more and he describes Ron grael as the
associate director of the white estate
he mentioned that twice he never was the
associate
director all right he wasn't he wasn't
sorry we we'll get to that get to that
again in a moment but Steve he claims
that you don't understand what the shut
door was about and you provided no
evidence like we said in the previous
clip uh in your book to support that
Ellen White had a vision regarding it
and that you make basic errors such as
claiming that Ron Gra bill was the
associate director of the white estate
when he never was apparently and that
all those errors call into question your
scholarship and reliability let's hear
your response to this and then Kevin you
can jump back in and you guys can get
back into this General topic of the shut
door I mean we can just read the shut
door quotes which I think we need to do
but um you know something people need to
keep in mind who are watching this
is cognitive dissonance is something
that causes people to hold on to false
beliefs and I've had all the same
beliefs that Kevin has had I was raised
up in adventism I was taught all the
stuff about Ellen White I went to
Adventist schools I went into the
Adventist Ministry uh he he's accusing
me of bias it's not bias to come to
realize over many many years as you've
studied as you've done a master's thesis
in history on Ellen White as you've done
two doctoral dissertations as you've
taught adven history for at least 15
years um and and continually studied
this stuff hey I was taught wrong stuff
you know that's it takes a lot of gut to
go against what you were brainwashed
with what you were taught uh the
cognitive dissonance is so strong oh I
got to keep my job I got to stay in the
church I got you know there's a million
reasons why people want to believe what
they're told in a cultic environment and
uh you know adventism has never been
open and honest about its history it's
always covered it up it's always lighted
about it as I said FD nickel completely
ignored shutd door documents that we're
going to look at right here uh that are
damning documents to him he completely
leaves them out when he knew good and
well that they were there that's really
sad you know and he's deceiving a whole
you know millions of people through his
books by doing this it's it's
unacceptable to say the least and um you
know it takes a lot more study and
research to change your mind when you've
been inundated with this kind of
thinking over years than to just confirm
confirmation bias if you want to talk
about bias what you have is confirmation
bias it's simply confirming what you
were told all your life and uh you know
you want to believe that because you had
good feelings about Ellen White when you
were a kid and so did I but I overcame
that confirmation bias it takes a lot of
work and study and research to overcome
confirmation bias the person who
overcomes confirmation bias has a lot
more credibility than the person who
just spouts confirmation bias I I would
you know first of all respond by saying
that Kevin let's hear your thoughts to
that and then I know Steve wants to read
some quotes and then I think there's
something that you wanted to bring up on
screen as well I'm trying to keep track
of all those things so things don't get
lost but let's hear a couple minute
response there to what Steve has just
said well let let um okay I'll do that
first
but you're you're using kind of AD
hominin sort of stuff here and I want to
deal with the evidence FD nickel may be
a place where I would start to look but
he's not my
authority I did my own
research I've
done like tiny Egghead pinheaded little
detail stuff that some of my fellow
Adventist historians say you're you know
you go real real shallow real on that
one that point you're really going deep
into that one point because I nail it
nail it down Michael Campbell good
friend of mine uh he said Kevin when
people look at your book they may not
agree with your conclusions but you
showed them all your work and that's
what I do so we can disagree but I want
to show my work and so that's what I
want to look at not how many years
you've you've taught or how much
experience you have obviously you're you
have a lot of background and I'm not as
old as you are but these gray hairs say
that I'm old
enough here's what I want to look at and
that is this is the testimony let's
let's go ahead and bring up on the
screen I'm just this is just my document
that will it's an adjunct to my book my
new book is going to be called glory
glory glory and it's on Ellen White's
earliest writings so I have the
documentation of each of the the parts
in it I I identify people hundreds of
people some that have never been
identified before I've done uh
genealogical research on it to to nail
all of these things down so I'm I'm this
is this is the area that I am deep in at
the moment I haven't published the book
yet and this will be a secondary uh
exhibit because I uh the publisher
didn't want such a big a long book so
this one will be available on uh the
Academia um website I'll just I'll just
flip that up here just so you can see it
here on Southern it's this this is the
link for it right there and um Jubilee
standard this is where I was uh I put in
some of this material so this is all the
documentation I put it here making it
available all right so let's let's
shrink that back down and we'll go here
and let me let me zoom in a little bit
on it so it's a little bit larger text
for everybody to be able to see this is
a testimony written in
1874 the same time that Miles Grant
wrote his his book or his first actually
it wasn't the book it was this was
published in the in their paper and then
he published the book okay so in 8
1874 this is JN Andrews a very careful
scholar by anybody standards
who he talks about his acquaintance with
Ellen White in the summer of
1844 I've been intimately acquainted
with her ever since conversent with her
course there's no nobody that would
question whether Jay and Andrews knew
her and here's his statement I do not
believe the statement to be truthful
that she claimed to have seen that
Christ would come in June
1845 it certainly did not come to my
knowledge though such must have been the
the case had it been true it is not true
that this prediction was published in
the Hope in Portland
1845 so that's the evidence take it as
you
will and and um and then when we go to
the other um issues when we talk about
the the finer points of what does the
shut door mean we cannot wave a magic
wand or or or gloss over
distinctions because there are
differences of view and as I have
studied this early period of millerite
History we see millerites a various
Stripes I'm sure you're familiar with
some of them you know the the the
conference that decided they weren't
going to do foot washing those that that
believed in the the shut door those that
didn't believe in a shut door those
there there were multiple different
groups that were coming out and the one
that James and Ellen White are with
accepted the bridegroom accepted the
shut door but their view changed now
within the documentation for
this this pamphlet you know well it's
pages I will agree with you that James
White very early in
1845 held the kind of shutd door view
that you're describing I will agree with
you on that because in his letter he
talks about doing a funeral service for
um Maran Davis's aunt she died her name
was Marian and he went to do the funeral
service he preached the the the hope of
the the resurrection from the Adventist
point of view and he knew that the
people there probably would not receive
it and he referred to them as as like
casting your Pearls Before Swine but he
was going to give his his his testimony
anyway so in early 1845 I will agree
with you that James White agreed with
had that view but the question is
whether Ellen White's Visions have that
same view and when we look carefully at
them there is a distinction now let me
go to hold hold up Kevin there's kind of
a lot there so we want to make sure that
Steve remembers all this I I don't want
everything to get lost so Steve let's
hear your response to that essentially
to to summarize Kevin is essentially
saying that again there is not evidence
and the evidence he he says you've
presented is essentially not sound
lucenda bick's testimony is not sound
but there's no evidence that Ellen White
actually affirmed the seven-year Theory
and that your understanding of what the
shut door is is incorrect so let's hear
your let yeah and let's hear your your
response to that and the quotes that you
want to read to uh show why you would
disagree with this I mean first of all I
already said that I can fit all the
quotes we've looked at including Ellen
White's denials into my theory very
easily um Kevin cannot fit in the a few
months three months however you want to
word that that's a very specific thing
saying that the time of trouble's going
to start in a few months um that's a
very specific thing he can't explain it
Ron grael can't explain it uh there's no
one I've heard who's an Adventist who
can explain that um it it fits perfectly
with the seven-year Theory oh is that
just a coincidence I don't think so um
why in the world would she say the angel
showed her a few months if the angel
didn't show her that um but and and now
he says he wants to take JN Andrew's
testimony who wasn't there in 1845 who
wasn't an
eyewitness he wasn't there when Ellen
White made the statement but lucenda
berdick was she heard it with her own
ear she heard it preached in the
churches and uh she was an eyewitness
that's a firsthand account Jay and
Andrews is just saying oh I don't think
that happened oh I don't care what you
think Jan Andrews your jobs dependent on
pleasing the whites I mean read
Gilbert's it's unbelievable Gilbert
Valentine's recent book on JN Andrews
over 750 Pages goes into great detail
and he shows how the whites treated
these younger people like absolute dirt
and he's an Adventist you know
Theologian still keeping his job and uh
you know he goes into how Ellen
confirmed James terrible abuse Behavior
by visions and Jen Andrews was one of
the victims of those um you know these
these young Adventists were kept in line
by James and Ellen and James was very
mean-spirited he did a lot of stuff that
was unacceptable Ellen confirmed it by
visions it's all in Gilbert you know uh
his book and if you don't if you haven't
read that you need to read it but um I'm
just saying I have read I have read your
book and understand that that's how you
see it I do understand that's how you
see it well let's hear Steve let's let's
hear the shut door quotes that you
mentioned as well I just I don't want
those to be forgotten yeah and and and
his statement about what lucenda
says it it you because you have come to
a certain conclusion even her statement
I hear you shaping it slightly in a way
that it doesn't say because we're we
don't have the statement in front of us
and that's why I want to go to the exact
statements and to see to read it out of
my book yeah that would be fine okay
just a minute let's go to these shut
door ones because they're right here in
my hand yeah because I haven't finished
my case for whether she she said a date
yet remember we're still holding on to
that yeah and and I would really
strongly recommend you read Donald
casbolt two new books because he
absolutely shreds Ellen
anyone who wants I've read part of his
book I'm I'm busy on my own so I haven't
read everybody else's yet I am working
my way through yours taking notes and um
and these are just some of the first
chapters I've you know so I mean if I'm
trying to keep up you have you have to
do a lot of reading if you're gonna be a
historian yeah if you're gonna write a
book on Ellen White early experience you
better be very familiar with Cas Bolt's
books because the stuff he says is so
damning to Ellen and so damning to
adventism that there's you know it just
absolutely wipes her out where millerism
is concerned and that's and and he also
goes into all the date setting that was
done there which I heard you deny on
that little webcast you did it was
completely untrue I've got more quotes
it when we can get to them well let's
hear Steve let's hear hear these quotes
and then anything you need to add after
that and then Kevin you can you guys can
go back and forth right her first Vision
um Kevin saying because she mentioned
the
144,000 that this can't be a shuto
vision we know good and well it was a
shutd door Vision she plagarized it from
Joseph Turner um Turner had written the
major work on the shut door it was in
Ellen's home she claimed she didn't read
it read it but after her vision Turner
asked her what she had said she told him
and he said that's exactly what was in
my paper so you know you decide for
yourself if she read the paper or not
but could I respond could I respond to
that point Steve you you'll have a
second Uh Kevin let's let's him just
finish the quotes we're gonna put a put
a marker there about that paper okay go
ahead it was just as impossible for them
to get on the path again and go to the
city as all the Wicked World which God
had rejected that seems pretty clear to
me God had rejected the Wicked World
doesn't that isn't that she said right
that's that door that's what do you
disagree with that that God rejects the
Wicked World I I totally disagree with
it when it's when probation hasn't
closed I know but do you reject do you
do you think that God does not reject
the Wicked World ultimately he rejects
the wicked world but he doesn't reject
the world war before probation closes
she's saying probation has closed
because he has rejected all the Wicked
World
that how else do you come up with that
otherwise he's just prejudging them and
they never have a chance to
change but these are people that have
made a decision that's what that's her
Point what even if people have made a
decision they can still change their
mind we believe in Freedom of Choice
your idea thatone fell off the path they
can't get on the path again are you some
kind of predestinarian or something I
mean no I'm I'm referring to the
specific wording of the statement
this this is clearly seen as a shut door
statement by any objective I understand
to a certain degree you there's a there
is a a a choice that was made but it's
in the quotations we'll get to that
later okay let's go to the next one
letter 31 1847 letter of Ellen White in
the L Lou SDA Heritage room Pages 49 to
51 at the time I had the vision of the
Midnight Cry her first Vision I had
given it up in the past and thought at
Future the shut door as also most of the
band had I know not what was in Joseph
Turner's paper I knew he had one out and
one was in our house but I knew not what
was in it for I had not read a word of
it this is typical Ellen White she's
always denying that she read the stuff
that she copied from over and over and
over again after I had the vision and
God gave me light he bade me deliver it
to the band but I shrank I was young I
thought they would not receive it the
very next morning Joseph Turner called
he said he was in haste going and
leaving the city for in a short time and
wanted that I should tell him all the
Lord had shown me in Vision it was with
fear and trembling I told him after I
had finished he said he had told out the
same the last evening in his paper so no
it wasn't a paper that's not a paper he
he was
he go ahead say what you're saying on
the subject of what was in his paper and
and so
ell and so Ellen White claims she never
read the paper but she just happened to
have a vision of exactly what he was
writing and speaking on I mean come on
believe that believe it with with all
due with all due respect Steve I think
you're misunderstanding which paper has
that in
it the paper you're referring to is not
the one one that is cited as having his
testim that testimony he had told it
just the night before he had just come
to that position when he left town he
went to Boston he shared with SS snow
and he had a paper published that does
have that new view in it the paper that
was published that was in her home was
published in dece
December and this was January by the
time that he published so the paper that
you're referring to that you you have
understood to be the one that she that
that corresponds does not correspond
number
two did you see the paper that was in
her house you don't have the paper that
was in her house I don't either but it
was common knowledge that Joseph Turner
was pushing the shut door View and he
was writing and speak speaking on it
that's what he was obsessed with it this
time not in not until January when he
went to tell SS no it's very important
to have all the particular if it wasn't
until January why did he tell her this
is what I spoke about last
night because he had just come up with
that view you said it wasn't until
January that is
January I mean you're not making any
sense Turner was known all right let's
let's give let's give the let's give let
us give
the um let us give the
chronology Ellen White had her vision
the latter part of
December
she uh the but the and the paper that
you're referring to that nobody knows
what's in it because it doesn't exist
anymore was published in December before
the vision he went and together uh with
with what was his name
Barnett they were they published this
new paper it is the new paper that
um um Miller William Miller cites when
he tells about this new view of the
bridegroom he does not site the one that
that was published this other thing it's
a
onetime publication there was there was
only one issue of it that they published
it and it was that that he took and
republished it is what William Miller
cites he does not cite something from
December he cites the one that was
published in Boston and that is the one
that is later so she says I know there
was a paper in my house I didn't read it
I don't know what was in it because I
didn't read it and he does not refer to
the paper he didn't refer to the paper I
understand how you think about it but he
did not refer to the paper he referred
to what he said at the meeting and if
you read the full context of that
statement she did not go because she was
afraid that all of the people would
disagree with that view because at that
time they believed that October 22 had
no significance whatsoever this was the
new view and the bridegroom View
that comes from him was was dispersed by
SS snow and then you see it in the mid
in some of the different magazines but
SSN was the editor of the Jubilee
standard so what you're saying you're
saying that you don't know what was in
that paper that was in the white home
but you know it wasn't about the shut
door that's what you're saying is that
cor because it's not the one it is not
the one that is cited
it doesn't matter if it was cited or not
he wrote a bunch of stuff and and a
different thing could have been cited
later but this is what he was pushing
like mad at this
time you have an assumption you have an
assumption that it's there you cannot
show that it's there I can show you you
cannot show that it wasn't there and and
well then then you have not then you
have no proof you cannot show that it
wasn't there but what we do know but I
can show you what they do site but what
we do know Turner says to her that's
exactly what I said last night right and
if she wasn't there would she know what
he said last night if because she got it
in a vision and that's why it was a
surprise this is the aous thing that God
just happened to give you know what
Dennis 14 recently said at the Ellen
White meetings in in uh October of last
year are you are you familiar with what
he was quoted as saying in those
meetings I I I don't know he said that
he was so devastated when he found out
for himself through his own study of
Milton's Paradise loss that 80 to 90% of
great controversy was taken directly
from it titles outline Etc 14 is the top
Ellen White scholar in the Adventist
Church today um you know you have to
face reality here someday uh you can't
just keep playing I've done extensive
study on great controversy I've done
extensive comparisons you can go to my
website uh to to Academia and download
the papers where I put them side by side
I have done that study I have done that
than Dennis 14 and you're you're saying
that his testimony there not ACC we
collaborated together on steps to Christ
my footnotes went into his his book I
have worked with
Denny so you're saying he doesn't know
what he's talking about when he said 80
to 90% of great controversy I can't
argue I can't argue in with Denny for10
In Absentia you know I am what I'm
disagreeing with is what you're saying
and I don't know that he actually said
that well he's qu I do believe that
that's how you understand it I believe
that you are absolutely
sincere I don't think you're trying to
deceive people this isn't an article in
Adventist today so it's not like hearsay
or something okay well I you know I can
look that up but but our viewers can't
see it so Jim Walter three-part uh
article just just finished recently in
adven today and Dennis 14 is quoted in
there saying this about Ellen white
great controversy and Milton's Paradise
Lost it's it's Denny Denny Fon and I
will look it up okay I don't all right
but let's let's get back to the
documentation so the point that I am
making is that you have made conclusions
you have drawn conclusions I understand
why you have drawn the conclusions parts
of what you're saying I fully agree with
there are on the documentary evidence I
have stated clearly what I agree with
you on but I have also given you the
evidence that explains why I disagree
with your
conclusion yeah and I don't I don't mind
if you disagree with me that doesn't
bother me at all I I mind if you mis
represent me on your webcast which I
felt that you did badly but um because
you
disagree agreeably let's try not to
interrupt uh Gentlemen Just because the
audience when when we do that it
actually cancels out audio and there's
nothing okay sorry go ahead go ahead
Steve all right let's continue through
these shut door statements um selected
messages to 34 and 35 after the passing
of time in 1844 fanaticism arose I went
into their meetings there was much
excitement with noise and confusion some
appeared to be Invision and fell to the
floor as the result of fanatical
movements such as I've described persons
in no way responsible for them have in
some cases lost their reason they could
not harmonize the scenes of excitement
and tumult with their own past precious
experience they were pressed beyond
measure to receive the message of
air it was represented to them that
unless they did this they would be lost
and as a result their mind was
unbalanced and some became
insane Ellen goes on to say that during
the same period She experienced a number
of visions and filled of the floor often
and such mental turmoil that for two
weeks my mind wandered and experienced
that she would later refer to her
extreme sickness therefore Ellen felt a
certain empathy for the many inmates of
insane asylums who were brought there by
their experiences similar to her own
that's just talking about some of these
charismatic extremes that were connected
with all this disappointment dat setting
stuff um Ellen White 1849 manuscript
release 593 present truth August
1849 I was shown the Commandments of God
and the testimony of Jesus Christ
relating to the shut door could not be
separated my accompanying Angel bade me
look for the travail of soul for Sinners
as it used to be I looked but could not
see it for the time of their salvation
is passed that's pretty clear this is
all the way back in
1849 the time of their salvation is
passed they can't be saved because I'm
going to present the other evidence and
I'm glad that you have present how do
you explain that evidence is what I want
to know if there if we can get to the
quotations I will I mean if the time of
their salvation is passed it's passed
but we know it wasn't passed Ellen White
was not telling the truth a manuscript
are you so shall I take a shot at the at
the quotations to deal with that
particular one or do you want to read
want to do it as we go through them it's
fine with me that way okay well let's
let's go to the screen miles if you
don't
mind we've I I need to do some catchup
because these are the ones about
specific date setting because the the
the the statement that we are debating
is did she set dates and so I want to
present this as evidence you have
presented General evidence that she
believed that it was soon you have
presented evidence that said uses the
language of few few months and that you
say fits within that that framework okay
that are we on agreement on that that
that's what you've stated all right so
let's let's take a look at her
statements in
1850 I saw that God had not made a test
of time since
1844 and that time never again will be a
test so she's she makes this very clear
statement it does not sound like she's
going to she's going to cast her weight
on another time test of seven years all
right let's go to the next quote can I
ask you a question related to that uh
sure I'll go back to it
okay all right you're you're saying that
uh God showed her you know there was no
test of time since 44 we've already
talked about her 2 and 44
we've talked about all these shut door
ones we talked about the uh a few months
one you said again she makes that in
1854 in 1856 she makes her food for
worms prophecy that people would be
translated in that room who were all
dead and gone more than a hundred years
ago now uh that was making a specific
time prophecy uh which didn't come to
pass once again in 1885 five she makes
several statements that I can read for
you here about it's too late to marry uh
it's too late to have children um time
is too short now to consider uh getting
married having a family um what in the
world she talking about that was 1885 if
people had taken her seriously uh there
would be no Adventist on the planet um I
mean she she was a confused woman she
contradicted herself all the time that
this is not reply this I Steve with all
due respect this does not reply to the
specific quotation that we're looking at
you're you're you're this is like we're
we're dealing with a spat between
spouses and you're bringing in other
stuff to try to bolster the case and I
want to be constrained so if you wanted
to reply to the specific one I'd be
happy for that otherwise I do need to
keep going yeah I already told you why
she made the these kinds of statements
later it's because the the time of
trouble didn't come as she prophesied it
would it's going to come in a few months
it didn't come so she can see it hasn't
come so now she starts backtracking and
getting all these other Visions to give
her a bailout position when it's obvious
that the Lord's not going to return on
October 22 1851 but her other statements
fit perfectly with believing
that that was going to happen it's only
when she sees that the time of trouble
didn't come that she starts making these
other
statements that's an obvious you know
that that doesn't reply to 1850 when he
has according to what I what I was able
to give you bates's statement about this
time period was made in March he
published his paper in March this is
October
of
1850 this is long before
1851 and she is saying
categorically that time never again will
be a test all right here's the next stat
say that the reason she says it is
because several months before she had
said three months a few months the time
of trouble will start in a few months
now keep we'll keep we need we need to
keep
going to keep going and the time of
trouble never started so because she
continues those same statements and so
it doesn't really support the seven-year
Theory
specifically it you in your mind it fits
I get that in your mind it fits I
haven't heard I haven't
heard that okay you haven't explained
the a few months uh statement because I
have not been enabled to go through the
quotations
well I've talked to because I have the
quotation that deals with that later on
so if we can keep going we can get to it
I'd love to hear where she gets out of
that a few month statement because she
doesn't I know it for a
fact okay could I proceed okay all right
the Lord showed me that the message must
go and that it must never be hung on
time for time never will be a test again
this is in June of
1851 this is long before the seven-year
period is over so she is categorically
again saying that time will never be a
test again she wrote not before it this
is already past the time when the time
of trouble was supposed to happen
so
now I okay I'm I'm G to have to ask you
to to hold off for just a second okay
because what we are dealing with
specifically is the seven-year theory
that goes from 1840 the fall of 1844 to
the fall of
1851 this statement is written in June
of
1851 it is several months before the
seven-year Theory would be fulfilled
therefore it is further evidence that
she does not support the seven-year
Theory she did not support it in 1850
she did not support it here in June of
1851 we
continue what did James White disagree
with what you just said well of course
you will because you have a different
you put the pieces together differently
but I'm giving you the specific
statements that are the basis for my
conclusion here is James White James
White says it is well known that some of
the Brethren have been teaching that the
great work of salvation for the remnant
through the intercessor of our great
high priest will close in seven years
from the termination of the 2300 days in
the Autumn of 1844 so he's he's laying
out that some believe that including
Joseph Bates some who have thus taught
we esteem very highly and love fervently
as Brethren and we feel that it becomes
us to be slow to say anything to hurt
their feelings yet we cannot refrain
from giving some reasons why we do not
receive the time this is in August two
months prior to October of
1851 then he gives his his answers and
the these are the I've just boiled it
down to these these three it's longer
the proof presented has not been
sufficient the message of the third
Angel does not hang on time we are now
emphatically in the waiting time in the
time of the patience of the Saints in
other words there is no determined time
that we have we are waiting and they had
come to that conclusion based on the
visions of the the bridegroom Vision
that she had in exiter based on the
visions that she has said very clearly
that we are not to have a time setting
and so when I look at these
authoritative statements made at the
time not somebody looking back who puts
it together in a different way but when
I look at the way that Ellen White says
it and the way that James says it it
does not give me any confidence that the
conclusion is a correct one I
respectfully disagree with your
conclusion now that's that's on the time
setting so did she set dates for the for
the Christ's return not done with the
shut door statements yet here here's
here's the statement from your book
would you like to read it for us since
it's from your book it is striking to
see how she evades mentioning Miller or
his meetings to say nothing of the
biggest issue which was the time setting
or date setting for the second coming
which Jesus himself specifically warned
against
okay yeah now you're in agreement with
that
statement
yes of course it's yours all right so
did Ellen White set any dates for
Christ's return and by that I am being
very specific I'm not saying did she
agree with somebody else's time setting
I'm saying did
she PR prognosticate now the the
strength that you have is one statement
from berdick and the early that it's
made is
1874 I have counter evidence from
somebody else who knew her which you
don't considered to be as valid as
berdick and I think that's that's
probably going to to happen over and
over again because you're going to agree
with the critic without the same
corroboration and I'm going to agree
with the person who confirms what she
says those are our two biases all right
so we asked this question did Ellen
White set any dates for Christ return
well the first thing we can say is she
accepted the spring of
1843 and the 1844 dates but was not the
one who set them can can we agree on
that statement yes okay all right
secondly her statements about The
Nearness of Christ's return referenced
no date aside from the verdict secondary
state statement do you have any that
gives a specific date for melon white I
consider the three Monon statement to be
a specific time setting
statement okay I I accept that that's
what you you believe it to be all right
we'll go on in the spring of
1845 she said that the time Setters
would be disappointed and therefore was
accused of delaying the Lord's return
so it does not sound like she was in
agreement with them very much does
it well she contradicted herself all the
time so it's okay you're all right is
there anything in her statements that
confirm that she agreed with the spring
of
1845 do you have any statement where she
she set set the date for spring of 45
because that's the only date we're
dealing with in this statement
yeah I mean it's not spring of 45 it's
June of 45 and then it's September of 45
all right very good
so saying you know berdick wasn't just
saying Oh Ellen happened to mention this
to me no this was preached and taught in
all the churches that was her statement
as she traveled with Ellen and heard
what was said I mean that big difference
between saying that and saying Oh Ellen
happened to say this to me no that
that's not what it was it was Ellen
being confronted by people hey why
didn't he come in June like you said he
was gonna oh because the angel showed me
in the language of Canan and I didn't
understand it it's really going to be
September um you know this is not the
kind of thing that bick's just going to
make up I mean it's just ridiculous to
think that that didn't her eyewitness
account didn't have credibility I I
understand that you give her credibility
I I give the reasons why I don't I
documented her life I documented the
connections and what I I don't fault her
statement first of all but I I fault
probably more the statements that that
overstepped it and that's what I what I
called on the issue of her being a close
friend there is not evidence of that and
I and I give the documentation for the
basis for even say she's acquainted and
I draw the connections I Trac the life
of of Howell I even wrote to Aurora
University I've been in contact there
with uh Susan Palmer she's the archivist
there to get the um the obituaries for
both how and for berdick and so I I've
tried to piece all of this together I'm
trying to be very careful in my
statements and there is no good solid
evidence to make it that she was a close
friend there is there is no good solid
evidence that is totally
supposition all right the next point is
she received a vision that declared that
the predicted October 1845 date would
pass so is she setting the date in 43
and 44 no but she had went along with it
is she talking specifically about
anything only according to berdick in
1874 is she confirming the spring date
no she is not is she confirming the
October 1845 date no she is
not and one more she received a vision
that time would never again be a test
she would make a test then she did not
why did she make a test to people
telling them to sell their homes why do
she make it a test telling them they
shouldn't get married why do she make it
a test they shouldn't have children why
did she make not test well they're used
that way when people are told hey the
Lord shown me you need to sell your home
uh that that's going to be a test to
them if they sell their home or even if
they don't sell their home you know
that's still laid out as a test the Lord
showed me you were to sell your home and
your property and your possessions the
Lord didn't show her that you are you
are putting a constellation of things
together that makes a picture for you
and I understand that it does but when I
have gone through carefully in her
statements about when she advised
someone to sell or not to sell it is not
an absolute sell all your stuff it's and
I and it is documented in my book that
she is saying there are some people who
have funds that can help the the
progress of the Advent message and God
will tell you when it is time to sell
portions of your property or more of
your property or not to sell at all
there are there are councils that she
tells people don't sell she there are
people that she's she's saying and and
the issue of marriage there's no blanket
statement don't get married no
the time pass for people to get married
or to have children the time has passed
was that a true statement no it wasn't
come on be be be honest I think I think
you are stretching the statement
unfortunately I'll read it to you I have
it right here so let's continue
on if you give it its full
context it is not an absolute
statement well Accord of course you can
always try to twist oh it's not absolute
but it's ridiculous but but you're
saying that it is we weren't even close
to it being the time for no one to have
children or not to get married that was
1885 come on do you have trouble with
Paul's statement on that Paul doesn't
make any statement that is anywhere near
what Ellen White makes in 1885 there he
says for the for the trouble that we're
facing it's better not to marry
yeah but he doesn't come right out and
say the time has passed to have children
or to get married he doesn't say that
and I would like for you to to to to
present that for our audience because
they need to hear it we'll read it uh
but I'm right now continuing on with
these shut door things all right this is
manuscript 11 LOM Linda Heritage room
page three and four then I saw the L
ofans dare they admit that the door of
Salvation is shut the sin against the
Holy Ghost was to ascribe to Satan what
belongs to God or what the Holy Ghost
has done they said the shut door was of
the devil and now admit it is against
their own lives they shall die the death
so she's Bas she's saying the people who
were against the shut door and her
teachings on the shut door had committed
the unpardonable sin and they're going
to die the death for opposing her views
on the shut door I mean it's just
completely ridiculous what she's saying
she's saying but where where does it say
anything about marriage that's what
we're asking for no no no I'm not
talking about marriage now we're coming
later back to that we're we're
continuing the shutd door statements I
let you respond to the one and then we
went off on a rabbit's Trail but we're
trying to complete these shutd door
statements and and now she's saying
people who you know opposed her shutd
door teaching and this is uh you you
know after 1849 people who opposed her
shutd door uh teaching have committed
the unpardonable sin the sin against the
Holy Ghost and they will die the death
for doing that I mean come on this this
stuff is it's really Blasphemous for her
to be saying this kind of stuff per
perhaps I could read the full quotation
do you mind if I do go ahead let me put
it on the screen so everyone can see it
all right that would that way it it will
be um miles can you allow us to do
that okay I'm going to see if I
can get it bigger I don't know if I
can there's there's supposed to be a way
to do this but
anyway all right this is the paragraph
that you're referring to I saw brother
Bates that he must put on put must
buckle on the armor said the angel does
thou expect to be free from trials fight
the good fight of Fate the angel of God
will go before thee and some Souls will
be benefited and receive the truth all
right so this is a this is a an
encouragement for Bates to do
evangelism then I saw lead Deans they
will make a mighty effort will they get
the victory one who has the truth will
chase a thousand and two will put 10,000
to flight they are coming to C
conclusions that bring them into Close
Quarters and they cannot tell where they
be themselves for they are lost in the
foggy terrible fear that takes hold of
them so this is the The Fog of battle
for the Le ofans anguish of spirit will
seize them dare they admit that the door
is shut the sin against the Holy Ghost
was to ascribe so what is she talking
about the door being shut right here the
shut
door well don't just use the the the
words she's talking about the here okay
let's read the context the sin against
the Holy Ghost was to ascribe to Satan
what belongs to God or what the Holy
Ghost has
done if somebody sins against the Holy
Ghost is the door shut they said the
shut door was of the devil isn't that
pretty
clear they said the shut door was of the
devil yes it is of the devil what Ellen
White was saying about the world being
damned and lost with was of the devil
they these people were right and yet
Ellen's saying they're committing the
unpardonable sin okay but you you didn't
respond to you didn't respond to the
sentence the sin against the Holy Ghost
was to ascribe to Satan what belongs to
God or what the Holy Ghost has done is
that a statement that's biblical yes
okay and so this shut door in sinning
against the Holy Spirit they say was of
the devil and now admit it is against
their own
lives I think there's something there's
something more here to be studied but we
are now into the the Weeds on this one
because this statement has within its
context something that you have
acknowledged is a Biblical teaching now
I would like to go back to the
statements that we were on real real
quick real quick um because I think
there I just want to clarify for the
audience um I think Steve's Point Kevin
is
that um what Ellen White is saying there
is that she is essentially saying to
reject the shutd door
teaching the teaching is to blaspheme
the Holy Spirit and what you read in
that quote there if you can read that
again for the audience to see it does
appear as though Ellen White is saying
to go against the shutd door teaching is
to go against the Holy Spirit and it
sounds like you're taking umbrage with
the phrase shut door there and and
saying and correct me if I'm wrong it
sounds like you're saying well when she
talks about the shut door here it's not
the shutd door teaching as you
understand the shut door teaching she's
referring to some other shut
door yeah uh almost almost what other
shut door is that okay it's a refinement
of her understanding of the shut door if
we if we use the broad brush then then
everybody would be in agreement with you
if we use the broad brush but I am a
fine detail and when I look at it I see
that there is a distinction that does
make a difference and so when we look at
the shut door that's what we need to
continue did Ellen White's view of the
shut door mean probation had closed for
Humanity and I did not know that I was
going to choose a font that was going to
go perfectly with your
setting all right bright yellow goes
with your stuff so did she did was her
view of the shut door that probation had
closed for all of humanity that's the
question okay now let's look at the
evidence here's here's where you make a
statement would you like to read it for
us it's your statement however it is
very important to note that the shut
door or closed of probation was
manipulated or I'm sorry was maintained
by Ellen White right up until the
seven-year Theory expired and Christ
failed and I also talk about how there
were three segments
to the shut door so it wasn't the same
view of the shut door she had all seven
years okay that's excellent that is
excellent because right up to the end
she's still saying that it means
probation is closed that you don't pray
for Sinners that's and that's where I
disagree but but I I appreciate that you
recognize that there is a distinction in
her understanding of it okay and that's
necessity it was out of necess
that the evanst people had to shift uh
yeah and that's and that is your
interpretation of it mine is different
because I have looked at the the
statements of those that were with her
and and and well we'll see it in the
quotations let's let's go to the
quotations here we go here's here is the
statement about which you quoted you I'm
putting it on the screen but I'm also
including more of the the inner parts of
it so that it's more in context if
that's all right I was shown that the
Commandments of God and the testimony of
Jesus Christ relating to the shut door
could not be separated she's saying the
concept of The
Commandments and the testimony of Jesus
Christ both statements coming from
Revelation relating to the shut door
could not be separated this is imagery
from Revelation chap 11 and chapter 12
okay these are this is language there I
saw that the mysterious signs and
wonders and false reformations would
increase and spread the reformations
that were shown me were not reformations
from error to truth my accompany Angel
made me look for the travail of souls
for Sinners as used to be I looked but
could not see it for the time of their
salvation is passed So within the
context who is she talking about within
the
context the context says the travail of
soul for
Sinners no back up a little back back up
a little bit but the immediate context
travail of soul for Sinners as know you
you you left you left out the sentence I
want want to have noted okay I saw that
the mysterious signs and wonders and
false reformations would increase in Sp
read the reformations that were shown me
were not reformations from error to
truth so the context is not talking
about all people of all times and the
close of probation it is talking about
people who have the opportunity to know
truth and refuse it now at this stage in
your life you may disagree that what
she's saying was pointing to truth you
have that right but as a Seventh Day
Adventist who still believes that she is
not being deceptive I I am pointing to
what she is saying as
describing what the salv whose salvation
is passed it is someone who has rejected
truth and affirmed their error
that's I want to interject you real
quick and then I want to interject you
real quick and then Steve I want to let
you respond to that and then Kevin we
can we can keep going back and forth but
I I just want to push back on this a
little bit here Kevin just to make sure
again to connect dots for the audience
because you're saying here that when she
says this phrase that the tail in there
for the time of their salvation is past
I know that you gave Uriah Smith's
typical defense to this um I I want to
push back on this because in one of your
earlier Clips you referred to the Camden
New York 1851 Vision which means that
you are under the impression which if if
you're citing euriah Smith there I would
think that euriah Smith um citing this
Vision as well and defenses for it in
the review in Herald um you you believe
that this is legitimate well this same
phrase is found in that Vision where she
says quote I saw that Jesus prayed for
his enemies but that should not cause us
to pray for the Wicked
World whom God has rejected when he
prayed for his enemies there was hope
for them and they could be benefited and
saved by his prayers and also after he
was a mediator in the outer apartment
for the whole world but now his spirit
and sympathy were withdrawn from the
world and our sympathy must be with
Jesus and must be withdrawn from the
ungodly close quote so maybe you can
explain for the audience how this does
not present a problem for the idea that
well one she claimed to Never See inv
Vision confirming that the Wicked World
had been rejected but also this point
here that well what she's saying in that
other quote it's not actually talking
about the world or all Sinners it's
actually only talking about these
specific people who um
Uriah Smith said um and I don't know if
you want to agree with him on this point
because you didn't bring this up but UAH
Smith said that she's actually only
referring there to false teachers these
teachers that were leading these false
reformations and false converts Etc but
um this quote does seem I don't know if
I've even read Uriah Smith on this miles
just to be honest well that's that's
fine um but that's the defense he gives
and I'm just curious how does this
statement jive with the idea that it was
the whole world when she says the whole
world okay well that's a good question
and I think you need to look at the
context of each statement because each
statement could be saying something
slightly different you know you can use
similar language to say different things
so I am looking to this statement in its
entirety not leaving out the middle part
to jump to some other
conclusion here in this quotation
we don't have it on the screen anymore
but this
quotation she is talking about a
specific group of people now um miles if
you want to bring up your quotation
again we'll take a look at that one and
I have I do have a response for that
one are you are you there yeah okay good
all right I saw that Jesus prayed for
his enemies but that that should not
cause us to pray for the wicked world
when Jesus prayed for his enemies on the
cross he was he was praying for those
who what knew not what they
did right there's a specific caveat in
his prayer for his
enemies we go to one of his other
prayers and he says I pray not for the
world but for those you have given me in
that statement our savior and I believe
we have the same savior Our Savior said
in that prayer he's not praying for the
world but he is praying for those who
have re God has given so in different
statements there can be a different
emphasis and in in this one there is a
there is a point now the question that
we're we're trying to
answer the the the question that we're
trying to answer is did she teach teach
that probation for all people except
maybe for this little group of
Adventists had closed and that's why
I've prepared these quotations because I
want to go to the specific quotations
not the general ones but the specific
ones so that we can see what she is
saying now here is her comment you asked
for this earlier Steve and this is her
comment because people did not
necessarily understand what she meant
the first time so so this is the
supplement to Christian experience and
Views I have I have the actual first
edition of these books on loan from a
good friend on my in my library this was
the
1854 explanation about things that were
not understood in
1851 they had published it for for many
years you know it had well not published
it but had disseminated had sold it had
given it and it's high documented in the
review that that it was a a well
respected and um and and dispersed uh
document anyway this is the passage
where she is describing what she said
before this view relates more
particularly to those who have heard and
rejected the light of the Advent
doctrines not just heard but
rejected they are given over to strong
delusions such will not have the travail
of soul for Sinners as
formerly again very specifically who
does she say those who heard and
rejected having rejected the Advent and
being given over to the delusions of
Satan the time for their salvation is
past those are the the words and now
notice what I've highlighted this does
not however relate to those who have not
heard and have not rejected the doctrine
of the second
Advent so can I respond to that M yeah
Steve Steve let's let's hear your
response to that I mean this is such
gymnastics to try to get around this
stuff but what we know is that initially
they took the stand that the world was
lost and only their little group could
be saved but then as those years
progressed there were people who were
coming and saying what what's what are
you about and they hadn't heard of
Miller they hadn't heard of the
millerite movement so they had to adjust
and and they changed their view of the
shut door so that only those who
rejected the millerite movement were
lost they were the ones whose probation
had closed they were the ones there was
no travail for soul this is all nonsense
by the way why should people who reject
a false message the millerite message
message was a false cultic message it
was stupidity uh this it was date
setting it was flagrantly against the
Bible why should people who reject that
be considered to be lost it's nonsense
those were Discerning people they saw
that this was not valid uh so they
rejected it to to lump them together as
a bunch of lost people whose probation
is closed is absolute nonsense and and
that's you know part of what casebolt
brings out so strongly when he shows the
complete stupidity of millerism and is
two books but um you know to to try to
justify what these Adventists did during
the seven-year period between all their
gymnastics and all their shutd door
nonsense and then to try to say oh this
was God's Great movement God did all
this God spoke all this to Ellen White
I'm sorry but I know the big picture of
Ellen White's whole life and that big
picture is not pretty and all this
garbage here at the beginning fits
perfectly with the rest of it that's my
story and I'm sticking to it I'm sure
because you're published and that's what
that's us that's usually what that's
usually happens people people don't back
out of you know it's it's um when
someone finds an idea useful in some way
way it's hard to let go of it I mean you
hav't any of my major stuff in my book
no one has there's not one having a
scholar that has reved refuted the major
footnotes in my psychobiography they
won't even come and talk with me on a
program you're one that wanted to but
you haven't ref I was not one who wanted
to Miles asked me to and I was reluctant
to do so Bas on the stuff you said about
me on your webcast I was asked about
your book by numerous people and I tried
to contact you numerous times on
Facebook and because I got no response
while they were still asking I responded
and I responded kindly I responded as
even-handedly as I could I did not put
you down I did
not I just said I disagree with your
conclusions here's my evidence now we
haven't finished all the stuff here
Kevin quick question on that just out of
curiosity um so you're saying that the
correct way to understand Ellen's claims
there is that it's actually talking
about people who have heard the Advent
message and reject it that would be
steveen I so are you saying then that um
you know I know you're trying to be you
you know you want to be cordial and
whatnot and this is kind of a forthright
question but um that's essentially what
you're saying you're saying that applies
then only to people like Steve and I
correct
is there any safety in rejecting
truth no not if it's not not if it's not
if it's actually true correct if
assuming that it we're we're talking
about what is actually true
correct but if you can't see truth to be
true but it
is then what have you done
well if it's actually true you've
rejected truth
right there's yours I mean how much
evidence do you need that a person's a
false prophet before you believe they're
a false prophet there's so much
overwhelming evidence on Ellen White
it's just completely ridiculous I I
can't believe well I I I have I've gone
into the Weeds on this and Miles I do
appreciate you giving me the opportunity
to respond because it's you it it gives
people a chance to to weigh it out for
themselves and I think that after after
tonight there will be a number of people
that'll say Steve proved his case and
there will be a number of people that
will say um I think he was not dealing
with some of the specifics that Morgan
was talking about and that's all that
we're going to come to there there are
people that will be inclined to accept
and some that won't I don't these kind
of programs don't generally move the
dial that much you know people people
tend to have their view but it's good to
have stuff out there it's good to have
discussions especially too if we're
making comments about people um it's
good to to have the discussions Etc
gentlemen I know it's getting late and I
feel like we could be here all night and
never get to everything obviously I do
want to play one more clip that covers
one more topic Kevin you will have a
closing you can use that five minutes
for whatever it is that you want to
share or close with um but I do want to
get to this one other clip there was a
there were a number of other clips that
we didn't get to just because because um
the discussion was was good but um let's
listen to this and then I'll open the
floor back up
okay now this is talking about later on
in Ellen White's marriage and trying to
describe it as uh being a miserable
marriage that had its bright spots but
that they were always contentious and
his assumption is that it's because
James knew she really wasn't uh a
prophet and so he was living with the
fraud and this is the this is the
premise of the book but um I was reading
this paragraph that referenced footnote
111 and one thing about this book that I
really like is that the footnoting is
consecutive through the book so it's
easier to find where you are you don't
have to look for a chapter and a number
you just look for the number he says
this is from George Knights walking with
Ellen White Page 73 so well I started
looking there in Ellen White's book or
the book on Ellen White walking
with Ellen White and
I looked up page 73 and started
reading George
Knight's description of this period
about the relationship with with James
and
Ellen and um rather than her considering
it a fraud this is what George Knight
says page 74 we'll get back to 73 the
fact that he firmly believed that his
wife's messages came from God didn't
always help his attitude toward her
since she occasionally had some pretty
straight words for him on such topics as
how his poor work habits injured him and
how he let his suspicions in depression
destroy his usefulness okay so humanly
speaking he may have resented what she
was pointing out and how that his
overwork which daily acknowledges that
she overworked let me let me just call
attention to that in the back of his in
his footnotes again going back to the
footnotes um she write he writes uh see
George Knights walking with Ellen White
Page 73 for examples of prophetic repand
that Ellen laid on James concerning his
poor work habits see letters such and
such and such and such but then when we
go back to his the chapter he describes
how that he had that um James had nearly
uh up to five strokes and um he was a
workaholic she he he agrees with Ellen
White so Ellen White's counsels to James
were not spoiling his fun it was trying
to help him to survive and so she could
keep her husband around whom she did
love dearly she called
him uh the best man who ever trod Sho
leather kind of a quaint little way of
saying it all right so get back to to
this passage and what's supposed to be
on page
73 well I started reading page 73 and it
says that stroke and his inability to
trust others or delegate Authority
colored the remainder of his life
problems that had been evident in his
early years became pronounced after
1865 thus he suffered from occurring
Depression was suspicious of other
people and at times made ill-advised
statements and
accusations these problems affected both
his relationships with fellow Church
workers and with his wife and
children okay that's
true um the depression and uh the
workaholic were were problems but he was
still productive and he still
accomplished a lot for the Lord and
loved the Lord and his
work but um this is how he James sty or
Steve Dy puts this after the first of
his five Strokes in 1865 quote problems
that had been evident in his early years
became okay single quote pronounced and
then he continues as if this were a
quotation his moodiness depression
paranoia suspicion and control all all
became increasing issues in a marriage
where he had to cope with a prophet wife
who was also single quote always right
single quote close
quote imagine my
surprise to look for this and find that
this is
DA's
summation
DA's superimposed ideas about her and I
could never find this quotation it does
not exist where he says it's supposed to
could come from and I searched the
internet searched archive.org searched
Google Docs um trying to find that
statement and the only thing I find is
the beginning of the statement which is
correct in page
73 about um problems that had been
evident in early year in uh in his early
years became
pronounced so Steve yeah there is Kevin
seems Kevin seems to think there uh the
the double quote should have come right
after the single quote um which was the
first part where I was actually quoting
him and I don't know how many books
Kevin's written over 350 Pages I've
written several and it's almost
impossible to write a book of this size
without having some small mistakes like
this the the um reference is in the
right place but the double quote should
not be in front of that reference
although the other uh references in that
quote uh underline what I say in the in
the paraphrase the paraphrase does not
disagree with Knight um Kevin's
accusation that I claimed that Knight
was saying he uh James didn't believe in
Ellen's Visions is not true uh there's
nothing in here that suggests that the
the part I quoted from Knight problems
that had been evident in his early years
became announced uh single quote and
then there should be the double quote
that's what was in my original but uh
there's a mistake there it doesn't it
doesn't negate the context it doesn't
negate the truth of what I'm saying
there and the references I give in the
back of the book but it is a mistake
I'll grant that but and what about
attributing something to night that he
didn't say uh in terms of the overall
thing night goes on and talks about how
James didn't want Ellen thinking that
she could tell him what to do and her
head wouldn't fit on his shoulders and
the same kind of stuff that I'm saying
here so it's not I never suggested that
Knight said that uh James didn't believe
in Ellen's Visions or said they were a
fraud he just made that up I don't know
where he got it but it's nothing that's
quoting I never attributed that tonight
no no no no I'm I'm you you said
Okay the Let Let me clarify what I what
my my question is I'm not yes I
understand you can mess up quotation
marks that's not what I'm that's not the
point um you know and I appreciate that
you can acknowledge that part of it what
I'm saying is you said specifically that
James knew that Ellen White was a
fraud and the refer the only General
reference you gave was Knight okay so I
other references that same
quote I I I looked for it I I I look for
it and when I went toight he says the
opposite of that point that's the point
yeah but I wasn't referencing that point
that was my understanding based on my
own study there you go there you go and
and if you had said and if you had said
I think that she thought he was a fraud
but the only reference that is given is
to take us T night and
series the series of letters and what
Knight says is that he firmly believed
that his wife's messages came from God
that does not sound like your conclusion
that he thought she was a
fraud and I have not found any
corroboration in anything that he said
or even that has said I believe that
that's your conclusion and I accept that
that's your conclusion but I don't find
that in evidence I'm Notting that
conclusion tonight okay so so that so
she I I don't believe see this is the
this is where I disagree with your your
interpretation of the events the fact
that they had difficulties in their
marriage does not have any bearing on
whether he believed that her messages
came from God all the evidence that I've
ever seen and even in the reference that
you that you reference he says he firmly
believed that his wife's messages came
from God so so he didn't have any doubt
the second point that I made and that is
I was looking for I really wanted to see
you know did George Knight say that
sometime did somebody say it sometime
that there that those the the special
quotes around
that she said she was always right now I
think that's probably also part of your
interpretation because I didn't find any
evidence that that James or or Ellen had
any ever said
specifically you know you you think
you're always right because James
statement about your head can't fit on
my shoulders and I'm tired of you
telling me what to do through prophecies
you know and he throws her testimony in
the you're throwing a few extra things
in there that are not in that statement
unfortunately no but I'm giving my
reasons for why I this is my personal
belief I understand James was very
expedient he was a snake oil salesman he
knew Ellen was his ticket and um you
know and of course publicly he's never
going to although he did quit publishing
her Visions in the review for four years
he was ticked off enough about the whole
shutd Door business and the seven-year
Theory uh he he cut her out for four
years till UAH Smith came in as editor
in we're we're getting into it in into
into a married couple squabble here you
know pulling stuff in to try to bolster
the
case um the truth is he never quit
publishing her Visions he didn't publish
them in the
review but they distributed the book
that was published in 1851 widely it was
available so he didn't stop publishing
hers and why is it why did they censor
all the statements about the shut door
and those things and and cut them out
after the 1851 date passed that's all I
will since we're running short on time
I'll refer you to that chapter in my
book yeah I I suppose you're saying they
didn't censor
anything no there's it's much more of a
context to look at each statement and
and I don't think we have time to go
into that right
now you guys can if you want I just know
that it's getting a little bit late um
so the the the choic is on you guys I
want to be respectful of your time um I
I do appreciate that it's better to
close yeah I I do appreciate the
discussion I think this was beneficial
for people to hear um and for these
issues to be discussed openly despite
the differences hopefully people were
spurned to dig into the issues further
and look at the evidence for themselves
in close you each will have five minutes
or so to say any final remarks that
you'd like Kevin we will start with you
your time will begin when you begin
talking and when you hear the sounds you
know the drill the first one is one
minute left the second one is your time
is
up thank you very much miles I do
appreciate that you invited me and you
kept your word exactly on how that we
this would go it gave me a fair
opportunity to present one side of it
and I do appreciate that very
much what I would say is that for those
who wish to look at a positive side I
think there's there's evidence to see a
different picture we can put the pieces
together in different ways depending
upon our lenses we will either see it
positively or negatively and we will
continue to contribute um whatever we
can find my mother and father split when
I was a child they didn't get an
official divorce but they were
officially separated and I noticed at my
dad's house one time a picture that he
had on his desk it was a picture of a
pile of clothes to remind him why he
left my mom a terrible thing to to
remind
yourself it's true my mom was not always
need about everything neither was my dad
but in the end of his life when my dad
developed dementia my mom took him in to
her house and for the last two years of
his life she took care of him during
that time he was lucid enough to tell me
how much that he had come to appreciate
what he had done what she had done in
raising us as kids that his negative
view of her was not an adequate
explanation of her that she was a loving
mother that she had given herself for
her kids and that she had done a good
job and she was he was proud of her in
fact he went to a service that honored
her at her
church I'm hoping that people can
reconsider what they have put in a
negative category that they can can look
at things and say maybe I was looking at
it with dark glasses and that there is
another way to look at
it from my understanding and
my careful research as I I study about
her I see a different view of her in
fact in one of my videos I quoted Steve
Daly and how he described her at that
time he at one time did have a positive
View and things have changed he has
accepted another view and he is
promoting that view I don't accept that
view and I don't hold to it and I want
to be respectful for those and recognize
that people see things differently I see
Ellen White in a very positive way and
her writings have been a blessing to me
I have benefited from them from the
beginning of my Christian Life and I
have seen in in context the stories that
I've read about her and that I know
about her that her counsels rather than
being being condemnatory have been
Redemptive One More Story I was doing
research for this book on Ellen White
and the Civil
War the goal of post-racialism and I was
reading about uh a fellow by the name of
Clark who went down to Texas in order to
to work there in a in a mission after
the Civil War this is moving along in
the 1870s is one of the first forray
into the South the Seventh Day Adventist
Church he was down there with a with uh
two other brothers that were working the
rust brothers and there was a a fellow
who was a blind man who got himself into
some problems he did some things that he
shouldn't have done Ellen White sent a
council down there and when she sent the
counsel the Brethren said yeah he's
doing the wrong thing and they pounded
him with it they took away all of his
positions and they pushed him to one
side and she said breth
that wasn't what I intended I wanted him
to correct those things in his life but
I wanted him to be
redeemed and I've seen that same picture
over and over again as she gave her
messages even though sometimes they were
cutting the point that she was trying to
make was to redeem a soul from something
that could prove their destruction and
in many cases did prove their
destruction I've documented some of
those cases from newspapers even in my
new book thank you very much for joining
us and thank you for the opportunity
miles and Steve I appreciate that you've
written a book that people can study and
that they can compare the evidence and
see for themselves which view they they
think is is
correct all right thank you for that
Kevin Steve the same now to you your
five minutes will start when you begin
talking all righty um just on that
marriage
quote page 134 of my
psychobiography she has two quotes here
time has been for years uh the bringing
into the children bring children into
the world is more an occasion for grief
than Joy Satan controls these children
the Lord has but little to do with them
the time has come when in one sense they
that have wives be as though they had
none how much better would have been the
influence of both if they had not
married um and she uh goes on and this
is in uh volume one of the testimonies
but both of the quotes are read and full
on page 134 of my
psychobiography but I just want to say
that um it's not coincidental that uh
not a single Adventist scholar has been
able to refute um not only my
psychobiography but the Ellen White uh
the white estate fraud um you know the
two book reviews that were written um
one was by Tim and one was by Butler and
and I just overwhelmingly refuted
everything they said in the two
appendixes uh three and four of my uh
White estate fraud book but um there's a
reason that you know Advent Scholars top
B and white people have been invited uh
by Miles they've been invited by Peter
Dixon they've been invited by
U Christian Scholars Forum not a single
one is willing to come on and dialogue
with me because they know I have the
evidence they know I have overwhelming
documentation for what I say and um you
know it's not coincidental that Ellen
White is a figure who has been opposed
by people from the onet you know while
she was alive from the very beginning of
her Ministry even in the early 1840s
there um I mean that's the reason I
wrote my psychobiography was because I
wanted to see if the overwhelming number
of critics both during and after her
lifetime would stand up to psychological
and historical scrutiny uh in terms of
her accusations of pathology and fraud
and I was overwhelmingly convinced that
they will um and now we have even more
more and more people jumping on the
bandwagon I'm very thankful that young
people you know like miles has come
along and uh I can go to my rest and
know that Miles and Liston and all these
young people that are looking into this
know that Ellen White was a fraud and
adventism is a deception and this is not
game a game to be played you know when
you have a false prophet a false gospel
people deceiving it's not coincidental
that the Mormons the jws and the sdas
all came out of the same cultural and
historical Meo they were all related
they were all founded by
frauds um you know Adventist want to say
oh were the true they're the counterfeit
we're the true no uh you're all
counterfeits and you're all frauds and
um that doesn't mean there aren't good
people in adventism I know a lot of them
I love a lot of Adventist people that
are just wonderful people I hold uh
Ellen White and the leadership
responsible for the deceptions that have
occurred it's really tragic that um you
know like Lincoln said you can fool some
of the people all the time and all the
people but you can't fool all the people
all the time and and that's what
adventism has tried to do over its
history and the bottom line is that the
internet is undermining them uh they're
dropping like mad right now they're
trying to hide the fact that they're
losing members like mad they're hurting
financially they're losing members
amongst the wealthiest part of their
membership they're in freefall so
they're desperate that's why Spectrum
would allow me to respond to Butler's
book review that's journalistic uh you
know that's just scum that's if you have
any journalistic integrity at all you
allow an author to respond to a book
review but Spectrum wouldn't do it at
interviewed me and then they got rid of
the people that did the interview and
took the interview off the website and I
mean adventism is really in a scared
mode right now it doesn't want to talk
truth it doesn't want to be fair doesn't
want to be objective it's censoring it's
you know ad hominum attacks all over the
place misrepresentations all over the
place place and it's really sad you know
I think more and more people are seeing
it every day I see new people on my
thread and um Kevin said he can't get a
hold of me it's the easiest thing in the
world to get a hold of me you just come
on my thread I'm on there every day I
post on it every day on my Facebook
thread anyone can say hey Steve I have a
message for you on messenger I
immediately go I say okay I look on
messenger for the message if you go on
messenger and I don't know about it I
have millions of messages I mean they're
ridiculous I have tons of emails I tons
of phone messages uh the way to get a
hold of me go on my Facebook page on my
thread say I have a message for you I'll
meet you on messenger and we can talk
priv it's not rocket science it's very
simple now I know thank thank you for
that Steve Kevin he went about from
anybody
he went about 50 seconds over if you
want an extra 50 seconds just to to make
sure you have the same amount of time uh
if you can if you can just uh put on the
screen what I put in the chat the
private
chat um oh not that that I was looking
for something that's not it in the
private chat okay yeah
yeah that's the book review that he may
not know about okay um I can send that
in the the our group thread off of off
of here and then if you want as well I
can link to that in the description box
down
below okay I will be interested and
reading your book Kevin so okay very
good gentlemen again thank you for being
here um I'm gonna let you guys go and
I'm going to shut things down so again
thank you for being here thank you miles
thank you for your work it's awesome
yeah thank you appreciate it all right
friends wow
wow so I hope that you guys enjoyed the
discussion I know at times it can get
crazy but folks you have to
remember I understand and I sympathize
with both of them when you're in a a
context like this it is very hard to not
go off onto other things to bring in
other pieces of evidence and I know that
that can be overwhelming as well for
people not just who are even Vaguely
Familiar but people who who don't
necessarily know the the general theme
of like the things that are being talked
about like the shut door so maybe you
need to go back and listen to some of it
again we have talked about these
subjects that we talked about tonight
many many times on this platform Steve
has discussed um different aspects of
his books in multiple streams on this
platform so you can go and check those
things out as well but there's one thing
that I want to close
on Kevin had mentioned there in his last
minutes that he hopes that people will
reconsider and to
reconsider would mean that you at one
point beli said
thing and I asked Kevin a very pointed
question there I had to do a lot in this
discussion folks to bite my tongue
obviously I tried to remain as neutral
as possible Kevin I want to commend him
for coming on here knowing full well
that clearly the two individuals that
are here um even though I was moderator
um he very clearly knows my position him
and I have sparred back and forth
actually on Facebook before um and I
have no ill will toward him I have no
bad blood with him I don't know him
personally um
but I had to bite my tongue a lot and so
there were so many things that I wanted
to say maybe we'll do a debrief um
stream at some point in the future where
we can kind of interact with with some
of that and you could hear some of what
I would respond to some of that stuff
with but he said he hopes that people
will
reconsider yet when I asked him that
very pointed question he said that when
Ellen White talked about the Wicked
World being
rejected that the time of Salvation was
passed that's referring to people that
once
believed their
message and not just their message there
were things at that time that were
present truth that are no longer present
truth today that you don't have to
believe that you did have to believe
then or you'd be
lost folks this is why this movement is
dangerous but I'm glad you guys heard it
that's what they teach you can look at
our archives on this platform
folks you'll find Adventists on those
streams saying we don't teach that when
I'm on their website saying this is what
they mean when they actually trying to
say no no no we believe most Christians
are actually in other denominations what
is my response always been yeah those
people are saved in ignorance if they
hear the Adventist message and reject it
they'll be
lost you have to embrace adventism the
best thing that the Adventist Church
could do is tell nobody their
message because then they run the risk
of rejecting it now they're doomed they
can't get back up on the path Ellen had
a vision about this after you hear the
message time is up for you so we can't
reconsider oh but what about all the
Adventists that have well that presents
now the other side of the coin of the
problem this movement is dangerous folks
it's
dangerous but I'm glad that Kevin is
actually willing to stand on a lot of
those
things and he wasn't in anticipating
that question you know I just I thought
I didn't know what his response was
going to be and I just wanted to make
sure to connect the dots for the
audience that that was out there so that
wasn't on our our list and whatnot so I
understand his his hesitancy to just say
yes I get
it he he did he he essentially got
around to to saying it but he didn't
just immediately snap call with
that and I get it that's a hard thing to
to have to tell
people but I'm here to tell you and
folks you can check the archives on this
as
well I've been consistent on this for
over a
decade I'm saying the same thing to
Adventist that's why this platform
exists I'm willing to tell you the harsh
truth I I don't beat around the bush
part of what drives me crazy about
adventism is when you get Adventists
that try and do this no no no brother
we're just like you brother no you
you're not stop doing that you're being
dishonest so I appreciate people like
Kevin who don't do
that you can call these people Fringe
Fanatics you know that's what the the
the types that tend to just be you know
the do o
types they get thrown under the bus by
their own movement when it's like well
no those people just have the
wherewithal and the guts to actually say
the teaching and I appreciate that I
appreciate that
but there is a fork in the road
here there is a fork in the
road you reject adventism after hearing
their
message their prophetess was shown in
Vision too late for you time of your
salvation's passed now I don't agree
that those statements are only talking
about those
individuals but just assuming that that
it is and going along with that we've
addressed this before we've looked at
the or Smith quotes and I know Kevin
said that he he hasn't read your Smith
but this is coming from the
Adventist milu you know I don't I Kevin
didn't just he wasn't the first one that
just came up with this that's the
defense that Uriah Smith tried to give
specifically and I mention this to not
just the quote that he read but
specifically the June 1851 cam to New
York
Vision oh they're they're being abused
it's not talking about the whole world
even though it says God's rejected the
the the the world the time of their
salvation is
passed meaning the world the time of
their salvation is passed but
nevertheless I I'm glad that we were
able to hear that I'm glad they were
willing to come and have the discussion
I appreciate you guys as well being here
next week we are going to be taking
Seventh Adventist pastor and apologist
Ivor Meyers scapegoat challenge where he
played a couple of clips from this
platform as well as another clip from
our friend EJ Thunder Lon you guys will
want to tune in for this it is going to
be interesting so until next time May
Christ richly bless you in the grace and
peace W by Christ in his vicarious death
on the cross for Sinners Hallelujah and
Marin
[Music]